Durante los últimos 5 años, la regla de
oro de la inteligencia artificial ha
sido simple y brutal. Si quieres una IA
más inteligente, hazla más grande. Más
parámetros, más GPUs, más miles de
millones de dólares. Y funcionó hasta
ahora, pero entonces nos golpeamos
contra un muro. Los modelos se han
vuelto tan monstruosamente grandes que
ejecutarlos cuesta más que la
electricidad de una ciudad pequeña.
Estamos quemando el planeta para que un
chatbot nos diga la capital de Francia.
es insostenible.
La industria intentó arreglarlo con
trucos como la mezcla de expertos MOE,
encendiendo solo partes del cerebro a la
vez. Fue un buen parche. Sin embargo,
Dipsic, la empresa china que tiene a
Silicon Valley sudando frío, acaba de
decir, "Eso no es suficiente. Todavía
están haciendo algo estúpido. Acaban de
publicar un paper revolucionario junto
con la Universidad de Pekín. presentan
algo llamado engram y no es solo una
mejora, es una acusación. Dipsik dice
que incluso GPT 5 y claw 3 son
fundamentalmente amnésicos. Cada vez que
ven una palabra, la vuelven a aprender
desde cero. Gastan energía recalculando
lo que ya deberían saber. Engram cambia
eso. Le da a la IA algo que los humanos
damos por sentado. Memoria real.
instantánea. Hoy vamos a desglosar este
paper. Vamos a ver por qué esto no solo
hace a la IA más rápida, sino que contra
todo pronóstico la hace más inteligente
en matemáticas y código. Si tienes
acciones en Nvidia, si eres ingeniero o
si simplemente quieres saber cómo será
la IA de 2026, quédate porque Deepsik
acaba de reescribir las reglas del
juego. Para entender por qué Engram es
tan disruptivo, primero tienes que
entender lo increíblemente estúpidos que
son los modelos actuales en cierto
sentido. Imagina esto. Estás leyendo un
libro y ves el nombre Alejandro Magno.
Tu cerebro no se detiene a calcular m
Alejandro, nombre masculino, origen
griego, conquistador.
No, tu cerebro hace un click instante
pop. ¿Sabes quién es? Es un acceso
directo mental. Es memoria. Ahora mira
cómo lo hace una IA tradicional. Aunque
haya visto a Alejandro Magno 1 millones
de veces durante su entrenamiento,
cuando ve esas palabras hoy, recalcula
su significado desde cero. Ejecuta
millones de operaciones matemáticas a
través de docenas de capas neuronales,
solo para llegar a la conclusión que ya
sabía hace 5 segundos. Es como tener un
amigo que cada vez que le mencionas a
Messi tiene que ir a Wikipedia a leer su
biografía para recordar que juega al
fútbol. Por lo tanto, estamos
desperdiciando una cantidad obscena de
cómputo. En lo obvio, el internet está
lleno de cosas repetidas. Estados
Unidos, por cierto, Nueva York, frases
hechas, nombres, datos estáticos.
Deepsik se hizo la pregunta del millón.
¿Por qué estamos usando
supercomputadoras para procesar frases
que deberían ser un simple copiar y
pegar mental? Aquí es donde entra la
filosofía degram. Dejar que el cerebro
deje de perder el tiempo en lo básico
para que se pueda concentrar en lo
difícil. Entonces, ¿qué es exactamente
engram? En términos simples, es un
módulo de memoria rápida que se le
injerta al cerebro de la IA. Deepsik
miró al pasado, a la vieja escuela de la
IA, antes de que los Transformers se
comieran el mundo. Recuperaron el
concepto degrams.
Un grama es simplemente una secuencia
común de palabras. Reino Unido es un
bigrama, dos palabras. El señor de los
anillos es un nama más largo.
La idea brillante de Deepsek fue, en
lugar de obligar a la IA a calcular el
significado de estos patrones capa por
capa, vamos a construir una tabla de
atajos.
Cuando el modelo B princesa de Gales, en
lugar de pensar activa el módulo engram.
Este módulo dice alto, conozco esto. No
calcules nada. Aquí tienes el
significado preempaquetado.
Le entrega al cerebro principal una
incrustación o embeding lista para usar.
Es como si el modelo tuviera una chuleta
o un machete en un examen. No necesita
resolver la ecuación porque ya tiene la
respuesta escrita en la mano.
Pero aquí viene la magia de la
ingeniería, cómo almacenas todas las
frases posibles del universo sin que la
memoria sea más lenta que el cálculo.
Aquí es donde los ingenieros de software
van a sonreír. Deepsik utiliza un
sistema de hashing. Imagina que tienes
un almacén con 1000 millones de
estanterías. Normalmente buscar algo ahí
tomaría horas, pero con hashing cada
frase tiene un número de estantería
asignado matemáticamente.
Si la IAB, inteligencia artificial sabe
instantáneamente, eso está en el pasillo
4, estante 20, caja 5. Va directo ahí.
En el paper llaman a esto búsqueda de
tiempo constante o1.
Esto es crucial. Significa que no
importa cuán grande sea la memoria,
puedes tener 10 GB de memoria o 100 TB
de memoria. El tiempo que tarda la IA en
encontrar el dato es exactamente el
mismo. Por lo tanto, Deepsik ha creado
una forma de escalar la sabiduría de la
IA infinitamente sin hacer que la IA sea
más lenta. Rompieron la relación lineal
entre tamaño y latencia. Y no lo
probaron en un modelo de juguete. Lo
entrenaron con 262 billones de tokens.
Para que te hagas una idea, eso es como
alimentar a la IA con una gran parte de
toda la civilización digital humana.
Usaron el mismo vocabulario masivo de
Deep Seek V3, 128,000 tokens. Esto no es
teoría, es una bestia industrial lista
para producción.
Pero espera, hay un problema obvio aquí.
La memoria es tonta. A veces banco
significa una institución financiera y a
veces significa un asiento en el parque.
Si la memoria escupe el significado
equivocado, la IA dirá tonterías. Pero
entonces Deepsik añadió una pieza
maestra, la puerta.
La Ian no confía ciegamente en la
memoria engram. tiene un mecanismo
interno, un pequeño detector de verdad
que verifica el contexto. Cuando la
memoria le ofrece un dato, el cerebro
principal pregunta, "¿Esto encaja con lo
que estoy hablando?" Si encaja, la
puerta se abre. Valor uno. Si no encaja
o es ruido, la puerta se cierra. Valor
cero. Es un filtro de calidad en tiempo
real.
Ahora, la gran pregunta de ingeniería
es, ¿cuánto cerebro deberíamos
reemplazar con memoria? Porque la
memoria ocupa espacio, los parámetros
ocupan espacio. Es un juego de suma
cero. Deepsic formalizó esto
matemáticamente y encontró el punto
dulce. Descubrieron que si le das a la
IA demasiada memoria y poco cerebro, se
vuelve tonta para pensar. Si le das
mucho cerebro y poca memoria es
ineficiente. El equilibrio perfecto es
dedicar entre el 20 y el 25% de los
parámetros dispersos del modelo
exclusivamente a la memoria.
Esto es una guía de arquitectura para
toda la industria. No es hazlo todo
memoria, es haz que un cuarto de tu
mente sea una biblioteca instantánea.
Pero espera, dirán los escépticos,
"buscar en una base de datos gigante es
lento. Esto va a matar la velocidad del
chat". Dipsic responde con ingeniería de
sistemas pura. Demostraron que pueden
alojar esta memoria masiva fuera de la
GPU. pueden ponerla en la memoria RAM de
la CPU, que es barata y abundante, y no
en la memoria V RAM de la GPU, que es
carísima y escasa. Gracias, Envidia.
Como el sistema es determinista, sabe
qué memoria va a necesitar antes de
llegar a ella. Hace prefetching, pide
los datos con antelación. El resultado,
el impacto en la velocidad es casi nulo.
Un modelo denso pasó de 6,300 tokens por
segundo a 6100, una caída del 2.8%.
A cambio de una caída imperceptible de
velocidad, obtienes una IA drásticamente
más inteligente, con memoria casi
infinita, que corre en hardware más
barato. Esto es una pesadilla para los
vendedores de GPUs de ultra alta gama.
demuestra que con ingeniería inteligente
no necesitas fuerza bruta. Así que, ¿qué
significa esto para el futuro? Significa
que Deepsig B4 probablemente ya está
usando esto. Significa que la próxima
generación de modelos no serán solo
cerebros en frascos aislados, sino
cerebros conectados a bibliotecas vivas.
Engram es la prueba de que no hemos
llegado al límite de la IA, solo hemos
llegado al límite de la fuerza bruta.
Ahora empieza la era de la elegancia.
Estamos viendo el nacimiento de la
memoria condicional, una IA que recuerda
como nosotros, piensa más profundo
porque no pierde tiempo en lo básico y
escala sin arruinar la economía. La
pregunta que te dejo es, si Deepsek está
regalando esta investigación al mundo
porque es open source, ¿qué es lo que
tienen guardado en secreto que no nos
están mostrando? Si valoras entender la
tecnología real detrás del hype,
suscríbete. Aquí no leemos notas de
prensa, leemos los papers. Nos vemos en
el próximo avance. Yeah.